c'est à l'école il ya le brave qui vient
t sur tesco 6 et 8 contrôle de maths je
vois là une non je n'ai pas voir combien
de fois ça m'arrive en contrôle sur toi
aussi tu nies en fait tous les énoncés
je regarde la lune comme ça tu fais ah
non là une déjà non je n'ai pas
troisième tu regardes tu fais troisième
as tu vois un shift ou non en fait tu
vois là 4 et tu vois que tu en fait t'as
rien de tout le monde c'est quand même
[Rires]
pas soit la piste du petit 1 passe moi
aussi d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
derrière déjà qui ne fait pas non mais
moi j'ai eu cette angoisse de contrôle
mais je ne dormais pas de la nuit moi je
rigolais les contrôles ou tu sais que tu
sais c'était une banane flambée
non il se doit avant je vais bosser
avant et vous alors ça doit être
l'histoire de votre vie non ce qui est
flippant secte il lit les feuilles de
brouillon
ah ouais toi tu crois que tu es chaud tu
as rempli une demi feuille de brouillon
tu vois les autres étaient un moment tu
te lèves et tu regarde combien ils en
ont plus que toi là à l'intérieur
toujours une femelle a les cheveux comme
at elle écrit tous elle tenait un moment
trois gardes assez simple
les avocats
ça
[Applaudissements]
mais moi mais parce que comment elle
lève les yeux là des enfants mais moi
qu'est ce que je fais à la fin je
remplissais débrouille j'écrivais des
joueurs de foot sur ma vie j'écrivais
n'importe quoi là pour faire du team
échoué et georges je sortais laquelle je
vais déjà rejeté dans l'ambiance
là c'était 4x plus de j'ai choisi de
contrôler c'est chelou
ah ouais moi s'il te dira sera à moi je
suis explique la journée je n'ai pas
pleuré parce que voilà je prenais sur
moi mais c'est vrai que tu as fait quoi
comme es tu toi moi j'ai fait le s
terminale es économie mon bac et après
après j'ai eu ça un petit 16 en espagne
au commerce et internationale j'ai
compris que j'étais pas dans le commerce
et surtout pas internationale et je me
suis fait virer aurais je suis devenu
drôle c'est sûr que j'aurais bien là et
bien et bien vous ne croyez pas si bien
dire puisque je n'ai même pas mon bepc
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas eu le bepc à 13 ans j'ai
voulu me marier pour avoir un diplôme
pour un truc tu vois et je peux en
gagner tout mariage et 13 en question
qu'à sa tête